vincent from the why believers book club
asked i'd like to say that i like to win
that's how i describe myself that's what
drives me i don't do it for the money or
for the bonus
is that my why uh vincent it is not
uh winning is a result
um and so uh we we all like
the win it feels good to everybody um
and the problem with
doing something for the win though it's
motivating
it's not inspiring is because after you
do
this that's dopamine you get a hit of
dopamine from winning right so you do it
once
you want to do it again and we want to
do it again and what happens if you go
through a whole string
where you don't win do you stay inspired
um
remember winning as a result inspiration
is an input winning is an output
um and so the question is what is it and
it's not just winning everything are you
that competitive that you would
if you're so driven to win would you
trip people and and cheat so you can win
that's the problem with being only
motivated to the win so the question is
is that the reason your friends love you
because you just like to win
of course not and our why is the value
we give to the world
that is bigger than the win more than
the win
and may drive us even when we're not
winning and keep us inspired
uh regardless of the outcome uh and it's
the reason our friends love us it's the
reason our colleagues love us it's the
reason our clients and customers love us
so your friends don't love you because
you're a winner
uh your friends love you because you
offer some value to them in their lives
that's where you that's where you want
to go
[Music]
searching
you